en este vídeo veremos la tabla periódica
y clasificaremos a los elementos en
grupos y mientras vemos estos términos
los marcaré de esta manera los grupos
son las columnas verticales en la tabla
periódica así que por aquí puedo ver que
todos estos elementos están en la misma
columna vertical todos estos elementos
están en el mismo grupo y llamamos a
este el grupo 1
puedo ver que todos estos elementos
están también en la misma columna cierto
por lo que todos estos elementos están
en el mismo grupo y llamamos a este
grupo 2 puedo continuar etiquetando mis
grupos este sería el grupo 3 4 5 6
11 12 y luego voy aquí arriba y puedo
ver que tengo otra columna vertical
tenemos el grupo 13 14 15 16
7 y finalmente 18 esa es una manera de
enumerar tus grupos hay otra manera de
enumerar los grupos y eso sería decir
que el grupo 1 es el grupo 1 y el grupo
2 es el grupo 2
y luego en cierta manera ignoramos los
grupos del 3 al 12
para continuar con el sistema de
numeración 1 a 2 y eso haría a este
grupo 3
7a y finalmente el grupo 8
y la segunda manera de enumerar tus
grupos es útil cuando piensas en
electrones de valencia y entonces
movámonos al concepto de periodos
un periodo es una fila horizontal en la
tabla periódica y entonces si veo el
periodo 1
me muevo a través de mi tabla periódica
el hidrógeno está en el primer periodo y
también el l
nos movemos al segundo periodo litio
berilio boro carbono nitrógeno oxígeno
flor y neón y entonces puedo continuar
enumerando mis periodos este sería mi
periodo 3
5 y 6
ahora nota que no tengo mi tabla
periódica entera en este vídeo no tuve
suficiente espacio y de todas maneras no
voy a hablar de todos los elementos
continuamos enfocándonos en los metales
ahora hablemos de los metales alcalinos
cuando hablemos de metales
intentaré escribir en rojo aquí los
metales alcalinos se encuentran en el
grupo 1 o 1 a elementos como el litio
sodio potasio
estos son mis metales alcalinos los
metales alcalinos son metales plateados
suaves y extremadamente reactivos y una
cosa buena de organizar a los elementos
en grupos es que los elementos en el
mismo grupo tienen propiedades químicas
similares y entonces los metales
alcalinos reaccionan en maneras
similares por ejemplo todos los metales
alcalinos reaccionarán con agua y los
metales alcalinos resultan ser tan
reactivos que no los encontrarás en un
estado puro en la naturaleza no
caminarás afuera y encontrarás una línea
de sodio en el suelo se encuentran en la
naturaleza en combinación con otros
elementos hablemos del hidrógeno porque
el hidrógeno también está en el grupo 1
pero el libro que no no es un metal
alcalino el hidrógeno es un no metal
déjame continuar dibujando eso en verde
aquí representaré a los no metales en
verde el hidrógeno es la excepción en el
grupo 1 ahora hablemos de los metales
alcalinos terreos
encuentras a esos en el grupo 2 o el
grupo 2 y justo aquí elementos como el
magnesio calcio y estroncio son de tal
es alcalino terios los metales alcalinos
terreos son reactivos no tan reactivos
como los metales del grupo 1 pero
tampoco los encuentras en un estado puro
los encuentras en combinación con otros
elementos y entonces nuevamente tus
metales alcalino terreos reaccionarán de
una manera similar tienen propiedades
químicas similares y entonces nuevamente
esa es una buena manera de organizar la
tabla periódica en grupos por ahora solo
continuemos diciendo que de los grupos 3
al 12
todos son metales aquí
y hablemos ahora de metales en general
por un minuto
los metales las propiedades de los
metales los metales son sólidos a
temperatura ambiente excepto el mercurio
aquí está el mercurio que es un líquido
a temperatura ambiente los metales son
muy maleables lo que significa que
puedes darles diferentes formas no son
frágiles los metales son también dúctil
es lo que significa que puedes
transformarlos en cable puedes darles
formas de cable por ejemplo el cobre
aquí tenemos el cobre los alambres de
cobre por supuesto conducen a la
corriente en las casas los metales son
buenos conductores de calor y de
electricidad esas son las propiedades de
los metales de las que la mayoría de los
expertos hablarán contrastemos los con
no metales los no metales si tienes un
metal sólido esos sólidos tenderán a ser
frágiles no maleables como los metales
los no metales son conductores pobres de
calor y electricidad encuentras a los no
metales en diferentes estados
materia ahora hablemos de un no metal y
eso serían los halógenos
encontremos a los halógenos en nuestra
tabla periódica los encuentras en el
grupo 7a o el grupo 17 elementos como el
flúor cloro y bromo aquí están tus
halógenos justo aquí los halógenos son
no metales muy reactivos usualmente son
muy coloridos muy corrosivos y el nombre
halógeno de hecho significa formador de
sal y de hecho volveremos a eso en el
siguiente vídeo cuando veamos algunas
configuraciones electrónicas y hablemos
de por qué estos elementos son tan
reactivos esos son los halógenos
luego encontremos los gases nobles los
gases nobles se encuentran en el grupo 8
a 18 muchos de estos son muy famosos
como el helio
neón argón crypton aquí están tus gases
nobles son gases incoloro y por lo
general son demasiado no reactivos y
nuevamente en el siguiente vídeo
hablaremos del porqué de algunas
configuraciones electrónicas hay otros
no metales aquí los cuales identificar
en un minuto
primero quiero hablar del hecho de que
casi siempre encuentras a los metales en
la parte izquierda de la tabla periódica
déjame regresar al color rojo y puedes
ver que tengo todos estos metales aquí
en el lado izquierdo y luego para mis no
metales en verde los encontrarás acá en
el lado derecho de tu tabla periódica y
entonces la línea divisora entre ellos
déjame continuar dibujando allí es como
una línea del zigzag déjame ver si la
puedo dibujar aquí
divisor a ir a algo así dibujaremos una
línea zig zag hacia abajo en nuestra
tabla periódica
y algunos de los elementos que
encuentras en la línea zig zag tienen
propiedades entre los metales y no
metales y lo llamamos metaloides
continuamos hablando de los metaloides
ahora metaloide por supuesto significa
como un metal son similares a los
metales pero las propiedades están entre
los metales y no metales algunos de los
elementos que están considerados como
metaloides serían el boro
el silicio
manuel arsénico antimonio
telurio y algunas veces verás a las dato
listado como uno de ellos depende del
libro de texto que veas puedes ver que
algunos de los elementos a lo largo de
esta línea zig zag son considerados
metaloides y no hay una versión oficial
de cuáles elementos están considerados
como metaloides y podrías ver
diferencias ahí para algunos de estos
elementos pero en general esos son los
considerados como metaloides el silicio
siendo probablemente el más famoso
porque el silicio es un semiconductor es
un metal dónde es como un metal si
conduce electricidad pero no tanto como
un metal estas propiedades intermedias
son algunas veces útiles
y entonces continuamos marcando el resto
de estos estos serían otros metales
cierto y luego por aquí en la derecha
tendremos al resto de estos no metales
el carbono es uno metal
el nitrógeno es no metal el oxígeno es
no metal el fósforo y el azufre y esa es
solo una manera rápida de dividir la
tabla periódica con algunas definiciones
simples en el siguiente vídeo hablaremos
más de la estructura electrónica y
entraremos con la definición de metales
de transición